[Music]
it's this week we've got penis plug okay
fair sex and sugar baby seeker awesome
take it away Tiffany yeah so for our
first story there's this product that is
called jiff tip and what they claim is
disgusting that apparently it's a
sticker that you put over the penis tip
to contain come why would you want to do
such a thing
disgusting wait yeah what is the reason
for that when you're not ready to come
yet then you put it on and do you put it
on softer hard apparently you could put
them on either way it expands yes looks
like so they're saying first clean the
tip you align the shields you bond it
and then so if it's it's like it's like
the the commas like this it's like
trying to come out wouldn't it hurt I
feel like that's not good are you that's
not gonna stop me it's gonna burst
through I'm gonna blow that thing off
you got a fire hose right I've tried it
stopping myself you know sometimes like
you're jacking off whatever and then I'm
not ready to go yet what do you do put a
finger over it you could try different
things you could like stop it whatever
but it still just leaks out it's like
this it's like this wait so you try to
stop yourself from coming when you're
jacking off yeah sometimes you're doing
the stamina training see I'm gonna train
you kind of work on odorants girls would
never understand that yep we do it for
you yep well you need to try a lot of
hahahaha
wait so you like try using your hands
like I've tried all kinds of [ __ ] before
else have you turn can I remember
anymore but I know you when I was
younger I was more experiment I've been
tried jacking off on the condom before I
wanted to see how that felt like what a
loser
hey we're gonna like 15 do you try la
stuff are you still doing that stuff no
I just come on my fingers I put it right
on the cervix like putting on the
contact like alternate contraceptive or
like a different form of a condo know
how strong is this adhesive where you
can't blow it off yeah that's all I care
about
that's scary to me because if it's that
strong it's gonna hurt it's almost like
getting duct tape and going like holding
that's like imagine like hold this
neither you know the pressure in your
head so we hold in the comment it goes
right back at our balls and it pulls up
our I hope they did some testing no well
they're saying that the small print on
the product is the fifth day that it's
not a condom and it's not a proof for
sti's or pregnancy prevention purposes
so literally has no use at all it's not
even gonna stop the sperm what if you
have all this pre-cum and it just opens
up the inside it's like a band-aid you
know like you have a bad day but then
the pus keeps coming out and it opens up
from inside maybe that's the point is
like you're you're able to like have sex
and then when you're getting ready to
ejaculate then you would peel it off
what's ejaculate we've no no it would be
a Jackie elation at busting nuts
okay busting that use the proper term
when you are ready to bust the nut you
would then peel it off
yeah and do it all over her stomach
that's [ __ ] chipped it but it's so
little too it's all like on it so is it
maybe it's pre [ __ ] prevention well
they're saying that it's a novelty
product
we're $6 yeah so it's $2 each it's a
pack of three um but yeah I think uh I
don't know if it was proven to work
though and let's say it wasn't like just
a steal like that like there's some sort
of pouch for it to come out in like like
a condom yeah but not like covering the
entire penis oh you can you can still
feel everything else it would just I
don't know I like condoms it makes me
feel sturdy you got a sore dick wear
condom keeps it compressed you know it
helps with soreness I was just thinking
like if it does peel in the middle of
sex or whatever right then how are you
gonna get that thing out of the pajamas
all right you gotta get some chopsticks
and [ __ ] and go in there that's true
that's why I like some free flow and
[ __ ] like that and if it costs two
dollars for one of them that's not gonna
be a very good adhesive that's gonna
come off this second any type of water
or liquid touches it so I don't trust
that [ __ ] we should just you should just
buy it and look at it and try it yeah
experiment I can't knock a product
unless I try it
my next story there was this couple that
was caught having public sex at a State
Fair is that the Wisconsin State Fair oh
thank god wait I expect horny kids
[ __ ] at fairs at fairs why are they
kids though are they cause [ __ ] kids
try to [ __ ] everywhere cuz they can't
[ __ ] at home
you ever tried [ __ ] ever you'll
remember being the kid I think of kid
like preteen yeah I think of teen as you
know I think a kid
and then you're 60 years old so you're
still a kid yes okay then yeah I [ __ ]
a lotta State Fair in Wisconsin yeah
probably dusty is like hey but turkey
legs get people going sometimes you look
at a goat and you get horny right the
goal doesn't turn you on but the fact
that you're looking at an animal and
then you see the go look at another go
like you could feel that primal
connection and it brings our primal this
out of you and then you look at your
partner an eagle we should go in the
haystack oh my god I don't know who he
is any State Fair I have have you looked
at go ice yep they looked like the devil
that's right you want their eyes are
like upwards is it go that's you I think
yeah I think it's like a rectangle right
mmm they taste good but they're the
devil you know this couple is not a teen
couple they are both 28 years old it's
been reported that apparently they've
they're divorced but they're having sex
period well cuz maybe going to the State
Fair just rekindled some old flames and
it was like remember when we used to
ride the ferris wheel together
did it say where they were having sex
like what was it like in the middle of a
concert were they hiding away somewhere
there in the blacksmith booth
gross so they're having sex on bleachers
underneath the direction on oh and so
someone saw them broad daylight that's
right they like and they were recording
them and they said something like say hi
to mom and that's when the dude turns
around and he starts waving shut though
and thrusting even harder stuff oh I'm
just laughing it off damn they look like
they having a good time though that is
just messed up yes this is a couple of
they were arrested but did he get beat
up too he asked me he's a wrestler oh
all the B's working the State Fair
they're just wrestling I mean he wasn't
in costume really yeah they're wrestling
they're practicing why are your hands in
this position what what what is going on
is your dad got some sex hair she went
immediately to the to the police station
they got arrested right after yeah like
once they were being recorded then they
went to go get damn he he [ __ ] her
pretty hard look at that her just all
rough do you think he was using the dip
tube
yeah Jeff did won't stop him there with
your kid inside I will be like hey you
want feed the animals yeah I will give
him some breadcrumbs so he could
sprinkle it on them would you record
them as well like whoever recorded these
people okay if I had a kid I would just
grab the kid and walk away and laugh but
I mean like if I if I didn't have the
kid I don't know if I would record them
yeah I don't know it just kind of like
recording is weird yeah that makes you
even creepier than this is a good moment
like sneaks out camera yeah I think of
all the things that you could say what
would you do I feel like I don't know
like I would either lose my [ __ ] and be
like you guys are disgusting what are
you doing out here cuz I if you have a
camera without a kid no if I had my kid
with me I would just be like okay like
let's let's just move away I don't even
want to get involved in that but if I
saw people doing that and I saw other
kids around that clearly saw what was
happening I'd be like I need to do
something and
you know what you know what's next level
I changed my mind while they're doing
that I'll drop my paths and stare at
them and jackoff oh my god if I didn't
go to jail because if I did that that
they would feel awkward and ending right
stop no what if they do what if it turns
of mind I gotta finish just kidding no
can you imagine that see just close your
eyes I can't I can't no facial
expression just yeah what did they were
like assuring you over like come here
just like this I'm walking over there
with my pants around my ankles they are
not an attractive couple I'm sorry I
can't do it I don't think I'd even get
hard watching them alright maybe maybe I
don't know that's that's a hard thing to
say cuz I don't want to go to jail but I
want to make them feel comfortable
dad just [ __ ] hold the mirror then oh
yeah this is what the [ __ ] you look like
you sick off that's good what if we get
a whole audience and start clapping they
look like they might like that yeah like
cheering I want in this way they are
interesting harder one but once he saw
his be recorded you're strange people
yeah so now for our last story there was
this man in Florida that has been banned
from a beach because he was passing out
these business cards that had said that
he was a sugar daddy looking for a sugar
baby what's wrong with that that's
pretty straight for 73 year old man
what's wrong with 73 yeah why was he
Bandar is that considered sexual
harassment what a thing or is it
soliciting I see it as soliciting its
soliciting yeah that's that's the reason
why you got bad you can't solicit on a
beach then I don't know that yeah you
can't and so he accidentally handed it
to a 16 year old yeah that's what I was
thinking
teenager so that cuz he said that he was
trying really hard to make sure that
everyone he gave it to it was over this
was he carding everyone like before you
handle about his business some 16 year
olds do not look like yeah he's
especially now bus or bus gave it like
he thought that she was old that's even
creepier big big bazongas yeah
toes her titties girl man way too
luscious to be 16 so like was he
determining their age based on boobs
I've only been about 35 year olds
because they be nature there are over 18
it was just like hey make sure that
Casillas business card do you I know I
know are we all forgetting that this guy
is 73 yeah no because all poor guy you
so lonely even libido is just not what
it used to be that's not true I've seen
a lot of porno where there's all but
like an old guy that's like man you got
you've seen Oh like on purpose no it's
just it just ends up that way yeah oh I
watched a sugar baby documentary and it
was all about like what they have to
favor is he why do you know Billy pop
she was like that's my favorite he's my
favorite one no but it it's not always
about them having sex like a lot of them
lonely strange but like there was one
couple and he was like an 80 year old
man and she was like 29 and they claim
that they have never had sex that
they've never done anything sexual but
kiss and he just sees her as like a
partner without the marriage involved
and he pays for everything ever
some people just like taking care of
people though that's like all it is
that's my mom yeah they have those
dominatrix that all they do is take
money from men because they just love
giving money yeah I so [ __ ] I didn't
need that no yeah let's take my they
wanted to be financially abused yeah
what are anyone of financially abused
people always fight actually abuse me
shut the [ __ ] up all the last thing I
abuse you for this freaking Maliki shirt
I bought it what the [ __ ] all these gold
diggers out there oh my god I feel bad
for him though he's 73 he's probably
super lonely the guy is clearly not
doing well in his life or like he's not
very happy if he's on the beach handing
out business cards that he made to try
and get someone to take care of he's
unrealistic and uh yeah he's just
unrealistic
why doesn't he [ __ ] my dick in his
[ __ ] only I bet you though you get
all the pens
it all depends on looks because if
you're imagining a guy with daisy dukes
on and his ball sacks are gonna be gross
but if you're picturing like Anderson
Cooper or Dos Equis guy looking like
sexy in a suit segaki sick in his
sixties someone like that maybe pilot oh
I wouldn't mind taking his business card
depends on the image old man Brett I got
that right now and I'm not even that old
no you smell oh not you but like if
you're old you smell old do no matter
what and I just pick your own pocket ass
up
that's true there's an aged smell it is
young boys and young girls smell a
certain way old people smell Aseema
babies I like the baby smile I did it's
like a little bit of pee pee a little
bit of coffee a little bit of baby
powder like then you were new or new
more new yeah like new new new no I'll
talk about toddlers oh they smell like
got that although they smell like caca
and diaper white he said that his wife
died back in 2003
he's never remarried he has a daughter
and a granddaughter he live out of town
he shot a [ __ ] girls younger than Ben
okay mo [ __ ] about your star you [ __ ]
nasty man stain your [ __ ] why would
you yo got that Dos Equis dialing so he
says quote I read in the paper about men
who have sex with underage women and
life is gone I can show you my bank
account I don't have any assets I don't
have money I just just enough to live I
don't have money for a sugar baby which
contradicts in everything the whole
point of a sugar he's probably just
senile then you're just crazy yeah I
mean look at my bank account I'm poor
but I want to give this girl everything
I don't he's saying that like he would
walk around the beach a lot and like
he's saying that about 95% of the women
that he would give these cards to they
would find it hilarious and he would
wear this shirt that also says something
along the lines of what the business
card says and that people would be like
oh let me take a picture with you
they're gonna post it on Facebook so he
was just kind of having fun with it oh
it's just like a comedian there so he's
like a troll he's like if he recorded
this on YouTube he'd just be grandpa
prankster keep on sex cuz then he got
banned was it worth it stupid huge
cannon bummed out about that because he
was like oh I think he's just looking
for some thrills but he did it the wrong
way
well you go up to a 16 year old yeah
well he did say he's like I messed up
when I said you're cute call me when
you're 18 oh my god so he knew yeah
that's funny
what would you do if you saw this
grandpa walking around in not the
speedos but those little short shorts
that they used to wear but you know no
he cut it to make it look like an
elephant so there's the trunk so that's
where his dick Oh Mike like the ears are
his are his balls that sounds awesome at
the sad oven that you don't know but
he's got stretchy skin so he would you
guys do if you saw that would you'd be
like that's creative like body paint Oh
like body pain or shorts no shorts but
then he cuts the hole so that it looks
like a oh I just want to know how you
thought of that I don't know it was very
funny in my head following somewhere in
the prop room not the thong but it's
there shorts and he makes it himself oh
I think it depends on how long the trunk
is I I'd let him [ __ ] me if I was a girl
what I'd let him [ __ ] me if I was a girl
what because I love artists I love
creativity and I love like passion
and I like a man who knows what he wants
[Laughter]
Joe hey guys thanks for watching that
last video make sure to follow us on
instagram @ JK films to watch more
videos right up there
[Music]